hey guys happy tech tuesday for today's
tech tuesday i'm not only going to unbox
the new call of duty advanced warfare
xbox one but i'm also going to be giving
one away to you guys
so before we do
this unboxing a lot of you guys are like
just saying you really don't need
another xbox and you're right i don't i
i'm not denying that but i pre-ordered
this xbox when it first
was made available to pre-order so there
was no way i was gonna cancel it and i
was just really really excited about it
because it's my favorite game and i'm
pretty pumped about it and just as a
little thank you to you guys for always
being so supportive and i know a lot of
you would really like to have a new xbox
one so i would like to be the person to
give it to you so stay tuned to the end
i made it really easy i tried to make it
only two steps
it'll say beautiful
you look really really
nice now the best part about the
advanced warfare xbox one is it does
come with a terabyte hard drive and most
of the other xbox ones have only a 500
gig hard drive i will let you guys
choose which one you want if you want to
get the sunset overdrive which is white
if you want to get this one uh whatever
i it's i'm here for you right now i am
here for you this is not sponsored this
is this is justine loving you guys and
wanting you to play video games with me
i need to have a lan party i need to
have a party i'm gonna have a party i'm
gonna invite all of my friends
all three of them
byoxby
bring your own xbox
oh my god it smells so good
it smells so good it smells so good it
smells so nice it smells like a fresh
xbox one
whoa
this controller
is beautiful i tried to get an advanced
warfare manicure but it ended up just
looking like absolute crap so
that's that and said advanced warfare
manicure
real slick all right what do we got in
here we've got
the usual suspects
i can't wait to see you
i can't wait to get you out of here and
into my loving arms you could be my hero
baby
oh
my heart will go
whoa
oh my gosh
you are everything that i've ever hoped
that you would be
ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls children of all ages
obviously over 18
because yes that's how old you gotta be
to play call of duty
it looks
really nice
so now what you've probably all been
waiting for what do you got to do to get
yourself an xbox
it's very simple
it's it's so simple it hurts
hold on let me get my my my notes
number one comment on this video why you
want the xbox one is it for you is it
for a friend what games are you gonna
play i don't know tell me a great story
but you can also tell this story not
only here on youtube instagram facebook
tumblr vine and twitter anywhere you see
me holding up a game of call of duty go
to that picture or vine or whatever it
is and tell the same story you can copy
and paste it to make it super simple
number two is also extremely extremely
important in the winning process because
it's how i'm going to get your email
address there's a link in the
description for you guys to go click
sign up and you will be joining the ij
army mailing list and let me tell you
how many emails i've sent out in the
past five years of having this list
not many but when i do it is usually
something super secret that i don't want
to post publicly on the internet so you
will be uh you'll be in the super secret
crew and you also have a chance to
to get one of these little xboxes so i'm
really excited because i i love you guys
and i always see your comments and some
of you saying that you aren't able to
get an xbox or it's just the only thing
that you've ever wanted so i read these
stories and i just really wanted to to
give back to at least one of you guys if
i could buy you all xboxes i probably i
would definitely do that maybe that
should be my goal in life trying to buy
two million xboxes for all of my
subscribers um i love you guys you're
awesome thank you for always being so
supportive i also always love when i'm
actually playing my games and you guys
are in my lobby and then you tweet me
the screenshots of how bad i did so i
enjoyed playing with you but don't make
me feel terrible about my skills i'm
having fun leave me alone um that's it i
love you guys i look forward to seeing
who wins i will probably pick the winner
within two days because
i i think some of you guys are going to
want to play some call of duty with me
so i'll see you soon thank you so much
if you have any questions um uh well i'm
here i'll be chatting in the comments so
i'll see you guys soon good luck and
that's it bye